when we think of an addict certain stock
images come to mind a homeless person in
the park sniffing glue a gaunt figure
with a heroin needle in their arm a
breakfast time vodka drinker
but such gothic characterizations
mask what is in reality a far more
universal and less overtly dramatic
though still pernicious phenomenon
addiction doesn't have anything to do
with what one is addicted to
it can't be neatly circumscribed to
those who rely on hard drugs or alcohol
in its essence addiction simply means
leaning on something it could be
anything because it prevents particular
ideas from coming into our minds
the addict relies on their chosen
pursuit to block unwelcome emotions from
storming the theater of their
consciousness
the particular object of their addiction
might be whiskey or marijuana but it
could just as well be their mobile phone
or ever more copious buckets of fried
chicken
one can be addicted to talking to one's
mother or cleaning cupboards doing the
accounts or tracking migrating birds
what the addict fears above all is to be
left alone to have nothing to do other
than to turn into themselves and to face
unbearable sadness or regret fear or
longing
the popular misunderstanding of what
addiction is lets too many of us off the
hook it allows people to claim that they
are merely going to the office again or
checking the news
toning at the gym or catching up on
football results
yet addicts are not evil or weak they
are first and foremost scared the
solution shouldn't therefore
involve censorship and lectures
rather love and reassurance
we should make moves to allow people to
feel as safe as possible about opening
more doors in their minds and confident
that they can handle whatever might be
skulking inside
it is never really fried chicken or
social media updates we like anyway we
are just at a loss as to how to begin to
reflect without terror on the course of
our lives
how to survive the modern world is a
guide to coping with the present it
explores why some key features of modern
life including capitalism advertising
mass media and the rise of individualism
can have harmful effects on our
psychological health